[Music]
please welcome to the be show I'm with
the author of cleaner teeth longer life
dr. Lena Garcia a dentist and surgeon
how are you how are you okay thank you
how are ya
one is that good thank god you're one of
the only we talked about this in our
last episodes one of the only dentists
that I found and we touched upon
reviving the Sunnah with this miss walk
that you knew we broke it down really I
know
amazing a mental bacteria yes and can't
go wrong with you can't go wrong at all
let's just say like a friend so I look
like a little bit yeah quick it's it's
amazing there are so many health
benefits you know there was absolutely
uh what are that what are the components
we talked about for healthy teeth well
all hygiene uh-huh right yeah
healthy gut yeah healthy oral yeah why
nutrition of core nutrition in good
hygiene and making sure that the
materials and the procedures you have in
your mouth are supporting your health
not supporting disease last time we we
heard you into and we talked about that
you know and that kind of goes with you
know your book you know clean our teeth
connecting everything not just focusing
on one element but everything you know
incorporating all that and there's an
interesting doctor his name is dr.
Weston Price everything person price
Italy and he was also a dentist correct
you're familiar with his work and one of
the chapters in my book is actually
referring to his work and he did a lot
of work in wood canals and nutrition
yeah
it's his work all started actually with
him losing a son or uninfected with root
canal a dead tooth and I think that
opened up a whole new research for him
and that's what we you know a lot of us
veins a lot of his first experience with
all of that and of course nowadays we
have our own experience after so many
years of his work in my case I've done
thousands and thousands of biopsies and
root canal teeth and they are very
infected teeth because they carry they
weaken Al's in that environment of that
teeth you have room for a lot of really
nasty microorganisms and they excrete
into the bloodstream around those teeth
and they cause sense of other problems
in a whole different area can be in your
knees could be in your heart and even
conventional medicine holidays are much
more aware what the mouth cause is to
the rest of the body so in our practice
I get a lot of patients referred some
oncologists and other physicians that
once the mouth to be clean before they
even do any medical treatments and so
you find that more and more even within
the conventional community people are
getting physicians are getting much more
aware the benefits of patients having
healthy mouth do you got do you guys
learn about is his is his book a
reference guide and conventional not
much fashion at all known before the
holistic community but he had been such
a pioneer no one I mean he went around
yeah and he studied all the different
cultures yeah and that's all what they
were eating and with the the the tooth
decays that weren't happening
necessarily in those communities that
they weren't exposed to the Western diet
yeah well why is it the study there
should be you know a mandatory textbook
in the dental schools yeah we have
really far away from back in bamboo
schools but in the holistic community
and holistic societies and associations
and
more of the it's growing I think
patience it's coming from culture it's
coming from patience that people are
looking and going like okay what can I
do in the most natural ways to help my
body and to help my mind my physicality
my energy and my spirituality I always
give as an example I eat well because I
want to be clear mentally spiritually
physically for that you have to include
the mouth as part of this puzzle of
healing or this puzzle of disease and I
don't think by any chance conventional
medicine is giving the hole any
attention they still give parts
attention so you have all the different
specialists including the dentist that
death dentists are an oral part of the
body specialists and they're there to
fix teeth therefore they're not
concerned of how the mouth is
influencing the rest of the body but
they're there to fix teeth and of course
it's priority two we have to fix teeth
but keeping in mind that those teeth are
sitting in a whole system with a whole
body that has blood supply lymphatics
that whatever is going through the teeth
through the gums through the bone in the
oral cavity it's affecting the rest of
the body it's the same blood therefore
he has to change this mindset in Western
price was there supporting and he
learned that you know not in the
beginning of his career either
eventually was his son's issue and that
I think that was a big inspiration for
him that an infection in the mouth could
cause fatal situations and he saw that
in his own case and I think nowadays you
know physicians are starting perhaps
even in the conventional world get a
little touch that if patients have gum
disease
that could influence the rest of the
body
so you know I see surgeons they're
getting more in tune with that you know
they want to make sure patients do not
have at least some of what they
understand a little better which could
be periodontal disease the gum disease
so then they wanted that to be solved
before they do surgeries yeah so it's a
little bit starting but it's a far away
because then we got a connect nutrition
with all of that because of the gut so
you have the oral flora with millions
and trillions of bugs you have your gut
you have different areas in the body so
when the mouth is healthier because
people are making choice of better
materials for the mouth or perhaps
avoiding that teeth and metal that could
be meddling plants and metal restoration
when you say mercury when you say dead
teeth that root canal root canal that's
a big one now yeah that is a mat that's
a common practice if what happens that
constitutes a dead tooth like what how
does your tooth become dead what happens
what are some common we have a fracture
fracture you have decay decay k gets
deep enough into the pulp of the tooth
where the nerve resides now the
conventional procedures to go in there
take part of the nerve out and replace
that with their gutta-percha material
whatever material they choose and that
choose now is not a life remember every
tooth in your mouth is like an organ
like your heart your liver he has blood
supply lymphatics has everything that
any organ has and if now the truth has a
root canal that means the truth is no
longer a life it's now a dead body in
your body and it did it does actually
act like that because now you have
necrotic tissue that was never been able
to remove because it's microscopic and
even the best endodontist which is the
specialist that does root canals even
the best one cannot reach all the deep
deep areas where nerves
is microscopically housing so that's
what we canõt is all about it's just a
dead body in the body I've noticed as
soon as the pain is there that's most
likely it's affected all the way to the
to the root to the nerve so you're
probably going to need a root canal once
the pain it kicks it it's probably too
late of saving the tooth so what do you
reckon what do you recommend now if
somebody is in st does that's that's
where there's a big business there with
root clay or that's a big fruit that's a
procedure that's very very common and
what do you recommend someone comes in
your office and they've got a fractured
tooth or is tooth decay what do you end
up doing do you advise someone to get a
root canal well you know I think
dentists they tend to run really fast to
do root canals sometimes you can have
decay that's really close or you can
have a fracture where the Tooth is
giving signs but if you have to take
into consideration other factors there
it's the patient under a lot of stress
is the patient what they're eating how
they're doing as far as the acidity that
they are building in their bodies and if
you can reverse a lot of those factors
you might be able to reverse the fact
that that nerve could survive you can
potentially reverse it you can reverse
the fact that the nerve is going towards
that dance there the nervous struggling
that is tired because there's the K
because it's flexure because there's
other factors they're grinding clenching
sometimes it really puts a lot of
pressure there too but if you reverse
that eating pattern if you reverse their
stress to a certain extent if they sleep
better if they take a little they they
start eating foods that are going to
support you know not inflammation
because this is what medicine is all
about right
cancers disease autoimmune disease and
everything to do with inflammation so I
applied the same the same philosophy to
if we reverse that inflammation you
can't definitely reverse the death of
the nerve that's going towards you know
not surviving or even the same you can
reverse that so we use homeopathy we use
digestive enzymes we use different
things to support I mean patients have
to cooperate they have to be aware of
what they are eating and they can
reverse it so you are going to take a
break but you've been practicing now for
what over thirty years or something like
that yeah yeah and you've seen this this
is a testimony you've seen this actually
being River all that time I will take a
break we'll be right back with more with
dr. lena garcia don't go anywhere
oh there's only one word is his
messenger there's only one well Jesus
wants his messenger back here on the
Dean show now what happens okay so what
do you do in this situation because
conventional you're saying right away
they'll they'll rush to to take out the
tooth and do the root canal right
because remember conventionally they
they are they're working in part right
so dentist is a specialist to take care
of teeth and if someone has pain in that
tooth they want to just go towards that
choose and fix whatever it takes and
they choose I'm thinking outside the box
yeah I'm saying if we change that
environment in the guts if the patient
sleeps better if they are more relaxed
then there's less inflammation in that
tooth and then nerves can recover not a
hundred percent of the time but a lot of
time how many out of let's say ten
patients 100 patients how many have you
seen that it's been able to you've been
able to reverse it where you can
actually save the nerves save the tooth
through this process I would say you
know eighty percent of the time yeah
we're able to do that the only time you
can reverse if the patient comes to my
practice already with a root canal oh
okay and how about how is there how far
down the line even before they got the
root canal is does the nerve nerve have
to be really bad damage is there is
there a point of no return
sure sure if you see an radial lucency
like an abscess in the x-ray then you
know if the swollen face and you know
that the process the nerve is already
bad they're just you know the body's
just trying to get rid of that dead body
there for you so it's a swelling in the
face or an abscess I'll bet you there's
a lot of people that are saying you know
I didn't have any
exactly and I have new talent me all
right unfortunately exactly the point
that I'm trying to make and make people
aware that if they are being guided by a
practitioner it's more open mind a
practitioner there will support them in
different areas to cover that puzzle
beyond the teeth and the gums maybe then
we can save a lot of teeth from dying
unnecessarily by the procedure of root
canal what did this amazing genius of a
doctor who went out doctor I'll go back
to him for a second he went and from
what I when i was researching looking
into his his exploration he saw that
people weren't having this kind of
dental decay when they were eating more
in harmony what were they were supposed
to be eating and and the teeth weren't
rotting away but then when he came back
so he went and live with these people
all right we lost a lot of these
communities indigenous communities that
he used to go and live with and study
their ways of life and then what he
conclude when he came back and now the
soda pop they were finding sugar white
flour all these things that I just
neutrally depleted that bugs won't even
go on because there's nothing in there
for eating it constantly each and every
day and conventional doctors they don't
really write you know address this do
you guys in that in the school no no
there is you know I went to you know I
was a surgeon in Brazil I graduated in
Brazil and then I when I moved to the
state's I went to Boston University and
you know I was 2 years working with the
medical students and we had none
literally none nutrition or anything
beyond that the surgical procedures the
restorative procedures the procedures
there were mechanically involved in
dental school or medical school so we
don't learn beyond that we don't learn
that the reason that those cultures that
Western plies studied were doing much
better because they didn't have the
coca-cola and
- peppers all those strange names for
poison you know and Pepsi concentrated
sugars with chemicals that create so
much acidity therefore the body is
filled with inflammation it's all about
that we can heal cancers we can heal all
immune diseases we can heal dental
cavities we can heal gum disease we have
to change we have to totally change our
minds the system nowadays supports
disease that's what makes money follow
money or justice or support yeah the
system supports disease because it makes
money business huh of course it's a
business you know why so many cancers
why so many all the immune problems and
all of that because it pays in a bigger
picture it pays much more people work
healthier eating better you know it will
be much simpler and I sure after thirty
years of practicing medicine that
nutrition is basic for any area of
medicine you need specialists like
myself being a doctor of dentistry or a
psychiatrist or a neurologist any or
surgeon any specialty that we work with
if we're all together aware of what you
know nutrition can do for our bodies
sleep and in 30 years of practicing
medicine I do not practice and I do not
prescribe antibiotics or pain medication
and I do a lot of surgeries so that's a
big one I mean it is a huge why every
time you go to the dentist I mean just
you know basic as soon as there's a
little bit of blood antibiotics antibody
no it's it's truly unnecessary and I
will go as far as say it's doesn't a
lack of awareness from the practitioners
and also from the patients you can't
just blame the practitioners because
many times
are going to really back for the drug
they are going to really assist on that
so it is a big issue and there's a lot
to talk about it and so us as consumers
clients being we have to be more
informed we have to do more more of our
research and not society we are
interviewing people like me
practitioners like me isn't it when you
when I was investigating this you know I
was looking at it open mind and looking
at both sides and just doing the
research I found that there was a also a
pioneer in the internet and Dentistry
another one forgot his name but he sent
I don't know how many thousands a
thousand of these teeth that were
extracted from root canals every one of
them I did - I mean did I give you that
information but yes I did you may be
thousands over my phone okay it's in
your book so what does that tell you so
now that means that okay so paint this
picture you've got a root canal now it
failed or what now you take it out and
then you send it to the lab like you did
right yeah and other doctors are doctors
and then they find out that it's
infected so that was living that chronic
it's necrotic and it's harboring very
pathogenic bugs and that's pathogenic
bugs they put out toxicity around all
that even did that teeth a root canal
teeth there's blood supply so the
toxicity that those pathogenic bugs are
putting out it's getting access to your
bloodstream so an infection in the mouth
now it's causing infection in remote
areas of your body because it's all
getting into your lymphatic since your
blood system and it's causing me
inflammation it's causing a Striders
it's causing poor beholder hold on you
just mentioned unease you mentioned
arthritis heart but we started with the
mouse
exactly so how do we end up all over the
body you type the same blood that goes
around those infected chronically or
acute piece the same blood that goes
around those teeth it's going around
your blood should
take a break because around your needs
because around you don't need joint in
your body we got dr. lena garcia and
this is some valuable valuable
information author of cleaner teeth
healthier life would be right up with
more of this exciting episode don't go
anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
there's only one jesus one season
messenger back here on the d show i want
to mention because a lot of times you
know let's say i started off with with
dismissal i'm fascinated I remind myself
sometimes like you and we'll touch upon
oil pulling yeah Jim always asked why
are you doing oil pulling it like I
forgot I'm right back on so I'll get
back on it for three four days and you
kind of slip always tempting with this
I've been on it for the last two three
days I'll slip away
so look here's an interesting thing when
you look at I have this at the Dean show
calm you look under you could type in a
search bar how to cure cavities the
Wrigley company conducted a study on the
MS Walk which was published in a journal
about agricultural food chemistry in
2007 and it talks about the mints lace
in the miswak extract extracted killed
about three percent of the bacteria
whereas the ordinary mints managed to
kill only three point six percent nobody
tell about the mints we're talking about
these some mention here that killed us
so much bacteria and that's one of the
things of helping to have good teeth
there's another study in the Journal of
periodontal tree that is appeared it was
done by Swedish researchers on the miss
walk and this this also concluded that
these the the miss walk was also
effective in killing much of this
bacteria there's one also yet another
study of comparing the two toothbrush
towards the miss walk in 2003 and it's
can be reviewed online at the website
the US National Library of Medicine
National Institute of Health in PubMed
PubMed is a big
research center for these studies but
how come there's you'll never
conventional medicine they'll never you
mentioned this they'll think this is
like your quack what is this is it took
of a tree but this is science now we but
it's hard to find it I have tried to
order you can order this big I got you a
couple frames oh yeah yeah I got you
more for you to have when you leave I
got this for you yeah but it's very hard
to to actually make it easy for people
people like it easy right they like a
fast bullet yeah I like a paste I even
got a light I know you're very good with
I got the Mojo a little bit I like yeah
by dissection I know that's very nice so
it's not as practical for people to to
use that but it's certainly it's a
beautiful thing yes I do it with the
brush natural yeah the brushing yeah I
don't stop the brochure well my website
has a lot of videos yeah
and has oral hygiene video which makes
it very easy for people understand how
to what you want again teeth its dr
vienna garcia calm is my you know my we
can get somebody to go what tell me tell
me this story you're saying that now
this patient came in had the medication
yessir they come in from new york which
i'm very honored to have patients coming
from all over the place because may
excite they travel from all over the
world to see you they don't find their
support they need by their their homes
so we support them we do phone calls to
patients to but many times they really
want to come in so i can see their teeth
either gums and diagnose better for them
and yesterday i had this patient from
new york
she's a professor at New York University
and very bright woman and she has mitral
valve prolapse which require used to
prophylactic antibiotics so every time
you go to a dentist and they do anything
in your mouth you need to take
antibiotics so she's been doing this for
many many years so now of course it's
very difficult for your immune system to
recover that many antibiotics
so many times she chicken Bartek so I
really messed up her gods so she's a
very very her immune system is
compromised number one because of that
and secondly she has about seven eight
dead teeth in her mouth root canals
which canal that equal dead teeth right
and then recently they added five marrow
implants well that was enough to push
her and now she is she told me yesterday
she doesn't think she has another year
to live and I told her said hold on a
second here
I think there's a lot we can do and help
you to guide you through improving your
immune system getting rid of those root
canals getting rid of those implants and
giving your body a chance to recover
allowing healing not to be so busy
trying to eliminate the toxicity that's
coming from those implants toxicity
that's coming from the deities and all
those antibiotics you have taken so as
far as missing you you won't need to
take any more in biotics we can
eliminate a lot of the source of
interference of toxicity in your mouth
you know for six months to a year you
need to use you know partial dentures
but just to support the healing and then
we'll see what you need I'm not against
implants I mean I do
what are you doing yet zirconium what's
the difference between those are
clinical images one yet the Titan many
plants are meadow implants therefore
with other metals in the body it's
causing what we call the galvanic
activity whose your saliva yeah and your
brain your thyroid they all have their
own their own nerve supply which they
have the innervation they have their
temple when you add a lot of metals and
you add this galvanic activity the nerve
system gets way more pushed and you
cause a lot of more impulses in the body
therefore in metals we don't use any
metals in the mouth at all so we do use
zucchini eggplant zirconium is a
different coin it's a ceramic and the
ceramic does not have our immune
response when you do some of the tests
like the melissa test in Europe and some
other companies that offer that kind of
biocompatibility test the the cornea
materials in the mouth it doesn't have
that effect in the body and and then for
every restoration everything we do of
course we do you know ceramic wire yeah
let's go back we got a few more minutes
left tell us about the root canal now if
you come to the point where you have
your first level at the point of no
return the first step is like okay you
don't have the swanee you got the paint
there's a way to reverse this okay it's
not the end of the line we talked a bit
about that and then you talked about
nutrition and some other things that you
can do there there you do a lot of these
things but most of these things they're
not taught in conventional school so you
really have to go to someone who's a
more open-minded who's gone above and
beyond the conventional methods that I'd
say but if someone's at the point of no
return now and they can't do this this
way what do you recommend now now it's
like okay I'm going to be with no tooth
here what can I you know the doctors
trying to convince me to put the root
canals not a big deal and he's that
person's got a degree I'm just you know
it's been my dentist for 20 years
well if and I see that happening where I
think people with some of those
infections and they're not ready yet to
make a decision where to go either to do
the root canal or extract the tooth then
we use in our practice ozone and we use
homeopathic antibiotics homeopathic so
they're not your you know pharmaceutical
antibiotics and digestive enzymes and
different things in nutrition is a must
here too
and you can count down the system you
can minimize inflammation while they're
making a decision and I seen a lot of
people
no longer having pain or no longer
longer having his abscess or they must
make a decision sooner or later they
will have to make a decision because
it's just going to take you know a
stress or them eating something or drink
and alcohol for that body to become
acidic and support that inflammation
that infection so in what I look for
when a patient is not ready yet to make
their decision it's to minimize with the
treatments with ozone the treatments
with all the things that I mentioned
nutrition is a huge thing if they don't
have the ozone so they don't have
anything at all at least if you change
your nutrition and you start eating
foods and and and that are supporting
healing which will be no sugars no
carbohydrates no flowers for a period of
time until you've your tooth feels
better and I guarantee that that alone
will help them to buy a little bit more
time so you can look for practitioners
that can support what now you know best
and you can't try to convince a
practitioner that is very used to only
antibiotics and root canals and very
conventional practices to help you so
you're going to have to look for someone
like me or you know someone similar that
can help you and guide you until you can
make that decision that made a lot of
sense to me because it's compared to
like any other organ that's dead you
know I got a dead finger you remove it
you have anything that's exactly get rid
of it so that's a dead organic that you
don't leave the dead organ in that just
matters exactly that's a good point yeah
you get rid of it but here they want to
keep it in and what you're saying is
holistic not just you're saying I mean
some of the top dentists in the world
are saying we've gone above and beyond
that this is affecting all of the other
parts and the confusing part is when you
go to you go to you know your standard
medical practitioner and you've got that
heart issue arthritis this issue exactly
there's never a connection with your
mouth and you've got to be very careful
with that because now they're going to
give you
a medication well if you do not remove
what's triggering that inflammation that
infection you're going to be taking
medications for the rest of your life
when that just piles up for more side
effects and more medications and you're
not really healing the source of your
problems so it's very important that it
comes from you first
and then you choose the right
practitioners to guide you it's just not
about giving all your power to someone
that it's not even sitting what you
already know now as a patient as a
person that the whole body has to be
looked as a whole not just a tooth or
finger or arthritis symptoms know maybe
their arthritis symptoms is coming from
a bad tooth or your heart problems might
be coming from the microorganisms that
are sitting in your disease gum if your
gums are bleeding you have an infection
in your mouth it's not okay it's not
just because your parents bled then now
it's okay for you to bleed it's not
genetic is only one quart of everything
there's three-quarters of everything
that you have control we can't change
everything there is you know all this
Wi-Fi now we're exposed to so much but
we have some control and what you can do
you must take control over that control
over your health that was another good
point you got you know you're on a
cocktail of prescription drugs they're
only matched only managing the disease
but they're not like putting a band-aid
over to check engine light and you're
not really getting rid of the root cause
where can people get the book well we
all write the book has you know cleaner
teeth longer life right this is all
about longevity my grandfather lived to
be 105 and I plan and I teach and I
guide people to do the same there's no
reason we're having short unhealthy
medicated life our minds our hearts our
souls are not even aware of all the
stuff
and that's why the mouth becomes a huge
part of that here's the book and
obviously you can look at dr. lena
garcia and you can find our website and
find ways to watch my videos they're
very helpful we also have educational
modules that we're developing in our
website so you can educate you doesn't
matter where you are you could be you
know in Russia you could be in any place
in the world and get the information you
need to start right now taking control
over your health I want to thank you
once again thank you for being with us
here today show God whether we can have
you back again thank you guys for tuning
in we'll see you next time subscribe if
you haven't already and tell them peace
be with you saw me